[Música]
el presidente de rusia vladimir putin
agudiza la crisis al reconocer como
independientes a dos provincias
separatistas de ucrania dónetsk y
lugares además ordenó el envío de tropas
a la zona para supuestamente mantener la
paz en la región que se había
autoproclamado independiente de 2015
el consejo de seguridad de la onu se
reúne esta noche de emergencia mientras
que eeuu anunció sanciones económicas
que prohíben invertir en la región del
dow más europa también prepara medidas
tenemos reportes desde washington y
bruselas
[Música]
los incendios forestales en el noreste
de argentina y en paraguay siguen en una
situación altamente crítica con las
llamas ya han arrasado más de 600.000
hectáreas en argentina y están
amenazando al humedal más grande de este
país
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle y es un
placer saludarlos y comenzamos a esta
emisión en rusia- porque el presidente
vladimir putin agrava la crisis que vive
con occidente por el despliegue de sus
tropas en territorio ucraniano y
reconoció a dos provincias separatistas
de ucrania como independientes se trata
de dónetsk y lugansk putin ordenó el
envío de tropas a las que llama
mantenimiento de paz para que operen en
la región lo que aumenta los temores de
occidente de que el kremlin ordene la
invasión de territorio ucraniano les
contamos más en este informe de gabriel
coll chen y arianna villacorta
vladimir putin firmó un decreto que
reconoce la independencia de dónetsk y
lugansk las dos regiones separatistas
del este ucraniano
consideró necesario tomar una decisión
que debería haberse tomado hace tiempo
reconocer inmediatamente la
independencia y la soberanía de la
república popular de donges y de la
república popular de lugansk tras este
reconocimiento putin anunció el envío de
fuerzas militares supuestamente para
garantizar la paz y pidió a ucrania el
fin de las operaciones militares
pedimos a los que tomaron y mantienen el
poder en quiet que pongan fin
inmediatamente a las actividades de
combate de lo contrario toda la
responsabilidad de la posible
continuación del derramamiento de sangre
recaerá enteramente en la conciencia del
régimen que gobierna el territorio de
ucrania
previamente el líder de la
autoproclamada república de lugansk
había pedido a putin que interviniera
para según él salvar miles de vidas
para evitar la muerte masiva de la
población civil de la república de la
que 300.000 son ciudadanos de rusia le
pido que reconozca la soberanía e
independencia de la república popular de
lugansk subir en el índice bis y más
ones que en estas regiones prorrusas de
la cuenca del donbass muchos habitantes
ya tienen pasaportes rusos entregados
por putin en done es una región de dos
millones de habitantes varias personas
salieron a la calle para clamar su
decisión ondeando banderas rusas
ucrania respondió solicitando una
reunión de emergencia del consejo de
seguridad de la onu que tendrá lugar
esta misma noche además el mandatario
ucraniano volodymyr selenski conversó
con su homólogo estadounidense joe biden
quien anunció sanciones que prohíben
inversiones en las provincias
separatistas entre otras medidas antes
desde washington nuestro corresponsal
cristóbal vázquez nos explicó de qué se
trata la orden ejecutiva anunciado por
el gobierno de uairén y a quienes
afectaría
esta orden ejecutiva afectaría a
estadounidenses que invierten que hacen
actividades comerciales y que financian
empresas o individuos en estas dos
regiones en dones y luhansk y pues
también afecta a cualquier individuo
coopere en esa región precisamente lo
que llama la atención es que la casa
blanca no ha anunciado todavía sanciones
formalmente a rusia a pesar precisamente
de que no solamente por tim haya
reconocido estas dos regiones como
independientes sino también que haya
enviado a militares para estas acciones
para este actividad de paz que él llama
en estas regiones hay que resaltar que
también el departamento de estado
concretamente el secretario de estado-
anthony blinken condenó estas acciones y
estas palabras de vladimir putin le dijo
que van completamente en contradicción a
lo que había dicho ya lo que se había
comprometido anteriormente rusia y que
además pues viola cualquier tipo de
derecho internacional y de norma
internacional
por su parte la unión europea y el
consejo europeo también anunciaron que
aplicarán sanciones a nuestra
corresponsal esther herrera nos ampliaba
más temprano desde bruselas
las reacciones no se han hecho esperar
aquí en bruselas tras el reconocimiento
por parte de vladimir putin de los
territorios separatistas de donets y
lugansk en un comunicado conjunto la
presenta de la comisión europea y el
presidente del consejo europeo charles
michel así como el jefe de la diplomacia
yo se aburre han recordado que este
reconocimiento de los territorios es una
violación flagrante del derecho
internacional de los acuerdos de minsk y
de la integridad territorial de ucrania
y por lo tanto la unión reaccionará con
sanciones los rumores en sucedido a lo
largo del día que ha coincidido además
con la reunión de los cancilleres
europeos aquí en bruselas en cualquier
caso el jefe de la diplomacia europea
josep borrell ha dicho que este
reconocimiento tendrá consecuencias y de
hecho pondrá sobre la mesa a los
ministros de exteriores sanciones qué
tipo de sanciones se van a poder aplicar
es algo que aún se tiene que discutir
así lo aseguran varios países europeos
porque creen que no es lo mismo un
reconocimiento que una anexión así que
falta ver qué tipo de sanción es algo
que puede ocurrir en los próximos días
así lo podremos saber en cualquier caso
la unión europea asegura que actuará con
firmeza y con unidad el primer ministro
de reino unido boris johnson relajó las
restricciones contra el cob y 19 en
inglaterra al tiempo que la reina isabel
segunda combate la enfermedad a partir
de este jueves quienes en positivo ya no
tendrán que aislarse además el premier
afirmó que eliminará las pruebas
gratuitas desde el primero de abril
johnson levantó las restricciones como
parte del plan que llama vivir con el
kobe 19 a pesar de que científicos y
opositores políticos han criticado sus
decisiones para hacerle frente a la
pandemia escuchemos lo que dijo el
mandatario
hasta el primero de abril les seguiremos
aconsejando que se queden en casa o si
dan positivo pero después de eso
animamos a las personas con kobe y con
síntomas de hobbits a que ejerzan su
responsabilidad personal sólo porque los
niveles de inmunidad son tan altos y las
muertes están ahora por debajo de lo que
normalmente se esperaría para esta época
del año que poder levantar estas
restricciones
y el monte etna en la isla italiana de
sicilia volvió a entrar en erupción por
su cráter sureste y ha obligado a cerrar
temporalmente el aeropuerto de la
capital catania durante este lunes se
pudo apreciar una columna de humo y
cenizas de hasta 10 kilómetros de altura
la erupción ha generado asimismo dos
ríos de lava que se extienden hacia el
este y el suroeste
elena ya tuvo una erupción en este mismo
cráter el pasado 10 de febrero
irán dice que hay avances significativos
en las conversaciones en viena que
buscan salvar el acuerdo nuclear de 2015
pero aseguro que quedan pendientes los
puntos más importantes teherán reiteró
que volverá a cumplir con sus
compromisos hasta que estados unidos
levanten las sanciones económicas que
tiene en su contra irán ha incumplido
parte del pacto desde que donald trump
retiró a eeuu y ha enriquecido uranio a
niveles mayores de lo permitido elemento
clave para producir armas nucleares
y una de las garantías más importantes
que pedimos y que perseguimos seriamente
es la capacidad de restablecer
rápidamente nuestro programa nuclear en
caso de que se alcance algún acuerdo de
viena este es un derecho esencial para
la república islámica de irán a dejar
una tarea de arthur atajar una
estabilidad vial
el ex presidente de estadounidense
donald trump lanzó una nueva empresa de
red social llamada red social luego de
que twitter facebook y youtube
eliminarán las cuentas que tenía tras el
ataque al capitolio del 6 de enero de
2021 hablamos a esta hora con samir
stefan experto en tecnologías redes
sociales y cofundador de tetera puntocom
señor stefan bienvenido a france 24
trump fue suspendido como decíamos de
twitter porque sus comentarios alentaron
a los atacantes al capitolio quién va a
moderar los discursos de odio en esta
nueva red social
cómo estás no es claro una de las
grandes promesas de la nueva red social
es precisamente el poder tener una
conversación abierta libre y sin
prejuicio de ideologías políticas dice
la propia página de la red social así
que todavía no tenemos bien claro ni
quién lo hará ni cómo será esa
moderación y podrá donald trump tener el
mismo alcance de propagación constructo
social en comparación con lo que tenía
en otras redes como twitter o facebook
pues la verdad es que en el caso por
ejemplo de facebook parte de la razón
por la cual se le permitió hacer todo lo
que se le permitió hacer es poner
engagement que logra con su base de
seguidores entonces esperaremos a ver
hoy ha sido la aplicación gratuita
número uno en la tienda de apple en eeuu
y sólo está disponible en esa tienda
sólo en eeuu esperaremos a ver si el
engagement se mantiene a lo largo de los
días bueno y qué significan números que
sea la más descargada que tanto lo están
haciendo bien que se diferencia de las
redes tradicionales
en realidad no sabemos qué significa
porque la gente la ha descargado pero al
parecer no se ha podido bloquear más ha
podido registrar y de nuevo un poco lo
que promete es no tener un esquema de
moderación sobre todo hacia lo que son
los más observadores y la ultraderecha
norteamericana que como tú lo
mencionabas ha estado en el ojo del
huracán por la cantidad de posts que le
han sido retirados en los últimos tres
cuatro y hasta cinco años en las otras
redes sociales y esto nos decía que por
ahora está sólo disponible en eeuu se
espera que esta aplicación sus social y
está disponible también para otras
naciones o no
si lo que dice la página de las redes
sociales que estarán próximamente en
android y estarán disponibles en los
otros países no se saben cuáles ni en
qué orden pero por ahora lo que han
dicho es que de aquí al 30 de marzo
están en una etapa de estabilización por
lo menos al interior de la unión
americana y precisamente hablando de
esta etapa de estabilización los
primeros suscriptores de tres social
informaron fallas técnicas de la
aplicación e incluso algunos tuvieron
problemas para iniciar sesión que eran
robusta es hasta ahora la aplicación en
términos tecnológicos
pues no pareciera que mucho y la verdad
es que los desarrolladores han tratado
de mantener su identidad un poco
aislada del ojo del público en general
entonces todavía no tenemos lo que
pareciera ser en realidad una estructura
que uno pueda decir
esta es una red con una buena
infraestructura tecnológica y sobre todo
con un alto contenido de privacidad y
que proteja a los usuarios perfecto
gracias amigo stephane por estar con
nosotros en france 24 y pasamos a otras
noticias porque argentina desplegó cerca
de 160 brigadistas para luchar contra
los incendios forestales que hay en la
provincia de corrientes y de visión es
un escenario similar vive paraguay donde
las que más afectan también la
producción de soya y la calidad del aire
arianna villacorta tiene los detalles
mis seis aviones tres helicópteros
159 brigadistas y todo el personal de
apoyo convocado por el servicio
argentino de manejo del fuego logran
contener los incendios forestales que
azotan las provincias de corrientes y
misiones desde enero por lo que el
gobierno pidió ayuda a estados unidos
brasil y bolivia y corrientes llama la
atención de toda la argentina obviamente
acaba de vivir una tragedia corrientes
pero hemos puesto todas nuestras fuerzas
para ayudar porque la argentina es una
no hay una argentina de accidente en
argentina periférica no hay pueblitos y
ciudades hay argentinos que necesitan de
que la argentina te levante
más de 600 mil hectáreas ya fueron
consumidas por las llamas entre los
argentinos hay especial preocupación por
las plantaciones de yerba mate es
crucial en su dieta que se encuentran en
corrientes paraguay que limita con esa
provincia argentina también se ha visto
afectada por el fuego este país el
cuarto exportador de soja en el mundo
advirtió que la cosecha puede disminuir
hasta un 60% este año para eso significa
aproximadamente entre 2500 y 3000
millones de dólares menos que no van a
ingresar a nuestra colombiana los
productores de carne también temen que
la escasez de pastos genere cuantiosas
pérdidas entretanto las autoridades
alertaron que la calidad del aire es
crítica en asunción por lo que el
ministerio de salud recomendó permanecer
en el interior con puertas y ventanas
cerradas
el poder judicial de perú inició el
juicio oral contra el ex presidente
ollanta humala por presunto lavado de
dinero en las campañas electorales de
2006 y 2011 así se convierte en el
primer ex presidente peruano llevado a
juicio por aportes de o de 'break' y es
que lo acusan de supuestamente haber
recibido dinero de esta empresa
brasileña y del gobierno de venezuela
para financiar su candidatura
presidencial la fiscalía pide ahora 20
años de prisión para el exmandatario 26
para su esposa nadine heredia y penas
menores para otros miembros de la
familia
las muertes en la ciudad brasileña de
petrópolis ascienden a 181 lo que
convierte a la catástrofe en la mayor de
la historia de la ciudad son las cifras
que dio este lunes el cuerpo de bomberos
que recuerda que aún quedan alrededor de
100 personas desaparecidas luego de
siete días de búsqueda
y cientos de personas se manifestaron el
domingo en varias ciudades de marruecos
para reivindicar mejoras sociales en el
país y en contra de los altos precios de
productos básicos las protestas se
dieron en el décimo aniversario del
conocido como movimiento 20 de febrero
que comenzó en el país en 2011 en el
seno de las conocidas como primaveras
árabes a diferencia de aquel año esta
vez las manifestaciones fueron aprobadas
por las autoridades del país
con esta noticia de marruecos terminamos
nuestra emisión informativa los
invitamos a que nos sigan a través de
nuestras redes sociales ya que se
conecten con más información en france
24 punto com nos vemos en minutos para
más
[Música]